the best part it is like my for my kids
I get to be part of something that my
kids can enjoy that's you've got a
six-year-old you know how much they love
it my kids are the same they just they
love the movies they love to play with
the toys they you know and I play with
them a lot with Lego it's such a fun
thing you can do with your kids so to be
part of it is awesome you're on Facebook
live right now oh that's a true this is
going out to the universe Kelsey do we
have a question from Facebook live yeah
Chelsea asks if you ever use the Batman
voice for your kids yes I do sometimes I
have been known to use it like would you
say well because I don't I don't yell at
my kids I don't believe in I don't think
that has any effect but sometimes when I
need to drop the hammer like you know
hey guys let's go you know iPads off
we're going to bed or whatever it is and
they're like okay you're like whatever
and then I go let's get those iPads off
now yeah I know like and they drop them
you know it works yeah yeah yeah cuz
they can feel the voice vibrating
through their mail out what's comment
there yeah through their chassis yeah I
know what's coming next yeah they know
what's coming
you